alright hi everyone my name is Aaron and
I'm curious who here wants to really
maximize the positive impact of the code
you write by show of hands so this is
what I think about a lot how can we do
this because we're going to be writing
code a lot that's the career we've
chosen we are blessed to be able to do
it that's my perspective and if we're
going to do that how can we maximize the
good what we're doing and one way I've
realized in studying different open
source projects is that if we design a
library of framework that other
developers can adopt and use and do so
easily in a way that solves big problems
that is one way that we can extend the
good of what we do so i'm going to show
you one way to one approach for this in
Python and it's going to be exploiting
something called magic methods who here
has heard this phrase before magic
methods hey there we go now magic
methods are hooks in the object system
many of you have heard of these and just
to show you how it works I made a toy
library that on the surface looks like
the pandas library the state analysis
library of anybody's if anybody familiar
with that now the way you use it is
something like this you say from fake
pandas important a class called data set
and you create an instance of it like so
notice that you're passing in the three
rows here or three key value pairs in
the dictionary to the constructor these
are labeled columns of data so what you
want to do mentally is take one of the
rows of data and then rotate it in your
mind and that becomes a column that's
labeled that makes sense with me great
now once we created this des object I
can they say DSP print and we get a nice
labeled set of data here right small
data not big data but we'll get there so
just looking this data really quick in
the a column how many values are
positive three of them in the B column
what's the biggest number what's the
second biggest number or team very good
now what we want to be able to do is if
we're designing a framework that other
people can use for data analysis we want
to make it easy to for them to do the
things they want to do yes so what we
want to be able to do is say okay you
can call whatever assume this in just a
little bit but I want someone to be able
to write is say is to reference dias and
then with square brackets have an
expression saying give me the rose in
this data set where the a column values
are positive and in fact i get this
object positive underscore a which is
another data set which i got i can then
print out so our this filter my rose
according to the criteria here right
there's no negative values in here now
here's another example we say okay give
me the Rose where the B column is
greater than 14 another example give me
the Rose where the relationship between
a and B is such that their total is less
than 20 this is the interface in the
library that I provided here someone can
you notice how it's very natural syntax
this is not something that will take a
long period of training to enable to be
somebody to enable someone to be able to
use it well agree yes or no pretty
simple right so now if you think about
it though there's something a little odd
here can anybody point out what's kind
of unusual on the first line
the operator which one the plus the less
than or either right right because
what's in those square brackets is
something that just using the normal
Python syntax it's something that should
evaluate to either true or false one of
those two literals at runtime and that
is literally one bit of information that
is not enough information to filter out
all the rows to get just the ones I care
about that makes sense so what's going
on how does this even work the answer is
something I'm gonna build all too but it
exploits these things called magic
methods and some many of you are
familiar with this many of you are not
these are these double underscore
methods usually we say you like to use
the word under as a shortcut so I'll say
instead of underscore underscore LT
underscore underscore I only have 10
minutes left so I'm not going to say
underscore that many times I'm just
going to say dunder LT but we have this
Thunder LT method that if our class
implements this method it's a hook that
lets it be used and with the built-in
less than operator and so on for greater
than equality all these these are the
magic methods that we're going to use
right so in this angle class example
very natural very mathematical is just 0
to 360 degrees very very natural weight
map mapping onto normal arithmetic right
but we can cheat we don't have to follow
the normal conventions of having these
methods return true or false we don't
have to do that we can have it turn
return anything so we're going to
exploit this to create a more usable
syntax
now here's my data set class this is
part of the code i'm going to show you
pieces of how this is implemented so the
constructor is very simple it has the
data which was at dictionary mapping the
label names to the columns right side
ways we have as calculate a link this
just just check the data say okay how
many rows do i have and if it's
inconsistent links then I raise a value
error that's what the num rows function
does and then we say self dot labels I'm
going to sort sort the keys and store
that separately just for convenience
that's what it all is happening in the
constructor here now next thing what
this now this thing we want to do is we
say okay if we have a column that's
labeled a I want to reference DS dot a
capital A and get a label reference off
object that's what I'm calling this so
what does that class look like well
actually how do we even get there we
implement dunder get adder that's how we
say dot a that's how we dynamically look
at what the label is the ABC column and
then get the label reference object now
we return that label reference class
what's in there that is where we put our
hack that is where we miss behave and
put in a magic method that doesn't do
what it's supposed to do you say Thunder
greater than GT method it returns an
instance of something called comparison
notice the arguments that are passed in
we pass in a label that's just a string
value that's the what is being compared
to when we say des and then in square
brackets the essay is less than zero
that would be zero here or three or
whatever the number is and finally we
pass in a function object operator GT
that's a binary function that will print
that will implements the logic we want
now how do we represent this comparison
itself we say ok well we just pass into
a constructor and we have a method
called apply because all this is lazy
all this means we don't evaluate it at
the very beginning we only
evaluate it when we say give me the rows
of data I want them now that's when
apply is called and it uses that
operation that binary function we passed
in to filter the data rows okay so this
is more about the let's look at the
comparison class a little bit more you
have the constructor and then you have
the about the apply the ply thing the
key thing to understand is it's done on
a row by row basis so returns true or
false this actually returns true or
false that's where the true or false
logic is finally finally surfaces so
here's a recap that actually I'll skip
over this okay the only thing left
actually so we're going down a rabbit
hole here right okay we're just going
down this rabbit hole so let's go back
up to the top again how do we make the
square brackets work to begin with when
we say D s square brackets and then put
in this thing that looks like a boolean
expression but it's not really a boolean
expression well we just use the get
items under get item method and we have
within it you won't read this code you
can read through it yourself or you I'll
give you a reference to it for later and
you can see what it's doing is it's
constructing a new data set with just
the rows we care about that's what it's
doing
now we can go further with this all I
just showed you was just for a simple
thing give me the Rose where this rose
value is greater or less than or
whatever this reference value but what
if we want to express relationships
between multiple columns adding or
subtracting multiplying what if we want
to implement logical and or
relationships much more complex
relationships what do we want to have
more equation like filters like here is
this y equals uh basically the sea
column plus 2 is less than what's in
column B we can do all of this and I
won't make you do it should I now here's
a source so I what I did is I
implemented all this so you just go I go
by the nickname bread symbol online
different places including github so if
you look under there you'll see fake
pandas this is my contact information in
closing I just want to say if anyone
here would like me to speak tap at your
group organization get in touch if you
have questions find me later thanks a
lot